can Jake Gyllenhaal kiss dude I'm not
Andrew Garfield sorry by the way is Jake
Gyllenhaal Andrew Garfield the answer
that is no I'm Steve Carell and I'm
Kristen Wiig my name is Michael B Jordan
you don't know I am here at the wrong
place
today we're doing a wire complete
interview autocomplete we're here
there's a white on a complete interview
yes we are the best question I've ever
been asked in my life okay who they is
Kristen Wiig shirt if you have you John
that's who they is Kristen Wiig shirt
which is shirt wearing I am theory what
sorority is Jennifer Garner in high beta
five Ohio is a chapter 5 5 beta 5 P iph
upper thigh me for micro Beta Phi 4 I
just love high beta 5 does Woody
Harrelson sing take a long ride on my
mother bag you know I'm ready
I'm so sorry sound person how did Chris
Pratt
got famous how did Chris break up how
did Chris Pratt not famous there we go
there's your answer do you guys wear
underwear I think they probably like to
just be free I'm saying that at least
boxer-briefs mind I mean dance come on
we do this in the look like you know
these are two cabbages
how did send me a little Jackson become
famous that's your fault not mine do
pose move yes it sounds like this mmm
[Music]
is Matt Damon dead I hope not not dead
well maybe culturally speak maybe I'm
over he's so dead is John Krasinski an
Eagles fan absolutely not
I'm offended you even asks I'm a
Patriots fan and I'm still not over it
not a card enemies and st. Vincent meat
christianmingle.com where is Matthew
McConaughey
now same place his elbow was five
minutes ago Suzanna sailboat
no no what color are Amy Poehler's eyes
get in tight get in tight who is John
Krasinski that's a great question and a
big question my identity is something
I'm still searching for so thank you for
giving me an anxiety attack by even
asking is Kristen Bell naturally blonde
let's very good well
carpet matches the drapes y'all do
astronauts drink their own pee well in a
sense yes we take the the condensate
that the system collects up the urine
and all that gets processed and then put
out of a portable water dispenser which
is right over our head so everyday
that's pretty much what we do Oh totally
play Diana Ross so how to get Jake
Gyllenhaal's Rohan Sahara do you know
scare that beat somebody's woke up
someone's taking your air terrible
terrifying well that was the dumb thing
wired autocomplete interview mm-hmm I'm
sure you're gonna watch it again right
now
the one question I have for all of you
is what Kristen Wiig eat shirt it's
something to ponder